[Applaudissements]
c'est très impressionnant d'être ici
heureusement je suis un peu préparé
parce qu'il ya quelques jours j'ai
voyagé dans le futur pour vivre ce
moment avant qu'ils n'arrivent
maintenant tout simplement
et vous est-ce que vous avez déjà rêvé
de voyager dans le temps pour découvrir
des lieux disparus inaccessible des
dieux qui n'existe pas encore pour
rencontrer nos ancêtres et assister à
des événements historiques
eh bien figurez vous qu'il existe
maintenant une machine à voyager dans
l'espace et le temps
c'est un ensemble de technologies qui
agissent directement sur nos sens pour
nous donner l'illusion d'être ailleurs
et vous allez le voir ces outils peuvent
modifier la perception qu'on a du monde
est potentiellement le changer j'ai eu
la chance pendant mes études d'être
formés à la modélisation 3d c'est à dire
la création de monde artificiel sur
ordinateur j'en ai fait mon métier et je
suis vite tomber sur des dispositifs qui
permettent de s'immerger littéralement
dans ces mondes je pouvais me balader
comme si j'y étais j'avais découvert la
réalité virtuelle
j'en ai explorer les usages j'en ai moi
même développés que ceux sous forme
d'outils de formation de visualisation
ou de divertissement et dans toutes ses
réalisations
je voyage dans l'espace et je voyage
dans le temps prenons un exemple je
travaille sur un projet dans lequel les
participants visite un monument très
connu il ya 4500 ans
c'est une visite guidée en groupe sur un
grand espace comme si on y était on
s'équipe d'un casque de réalité
virtuelle et on se retrouve en egypte
pendant 45 minutes on va arpenter le
plateau de gizeh la pyramide de khéops
on va découvrir son architecture
son usage même et assister aux
funérailles du roi
imaginez vous retrouver au pied de la
grande pyramide pouvez vous rendre
compte de la hauteur de la dernière
merveilles du monde antique
quand on entre dans la pyramide virtuel
on est oppressé par l'étroitesse des
tunnels dans le couloir de la chambre de
la reine on peut voir les participants
se baisser pour éviter de se cogner on
ressent même le vertige qu'on se déplace
au sommet finalement c'est comme en vrai
à la fin de cette expérience
je vous garantis les participants ont la
sensation de connaître au keops comme
s'il y était vraiment aller et ça c'est
parce que en réalité virtuelle nocence
fonctionne comme dans la vie réelle plus
oui parfois toucher parfois odorat et
surtout ce qu'on appelle la
proprioception c'est notre faculté à
nous figurer la position et les
mouvements de notre corps dans l'espace
si vous testez ces technologies vous
verrez il est parfois difficile de faire
la différence entre réel et virtuel
la grande force de la réalité virtuelle
c'est ça c'est l'immersion et ce n'est
pas tout j'utilise mon corps comme dans
la vraie vie je marche pour avancer je
tends le bras pour prendre un objet
j'observe j'écoute je me déplace je
manipule comme dans la réalité on doit
avancer pour en savoir plus et nous
avons un impact sur ce qu'il se passe
l'autre force de la réalité virtuelle
c'est donc l'interactivité immersion et
interactivité nous donne le sentiment
d'exister à l'intérieur du monde virtuel
dans cette expérience on extrait donc
les participants de leur réalité
physique pour changer
virtuellement de temps et de lieu alors
là je vous donne l'exemple de l'egypte
de la ivème dynastie mais ya pas de
limite à ce que nous pouvons vivre en
réalité virtuelle est ce que ça vous
plairait pas de poser le pied sur la
lune avec armstrong ou de vous retrouver
devant mona lisa quand leonard de vinci
la partie
avec cette technologie on peut vivre le
passé comme nous vivons notre présent on
peut faire l'expérience de notre
histoire
c'est une nouvelle perspective sur le
monde qui peut nous aider à mieux le
comprendre
et puis ça c'est le passé mais on peut
aussi voyager dans le présent cas sans
les contraintes des espaces pour
découvrir des personnes ou des lieux
quasi inaccessible imaginez vous entrez
dans une caisse
vous entendez des pas vous retourner et
vous voyez deux hommes d'apparence
plutôt menaçante et ils vous interpelle
ce sont des combattants des combattants
de conflit réel des conflits qui sont
toujours en cours à l'heure actuelle si
vous faites le choix de vous approcher
ils vous parlent et ils vous expliquent
leur vie dans ces guerres qu'ils sont en
train de subir pendant 50 minutes
vous rencontrez six combattants de
factions opposées ça c'est une autre
expérience en réalité virtuelle à
laquelle j'ai eu la chance de contribuer
elle donne l'opportunité à des
participants d'entendre des témoignages
quasi direct de personnes qui vivent
dans le même monde que nous mais dans
des conditions radicalement différentes
pourtant au début de la production ce
projet je ne savais pas du tout si ça
allait marcher
si les participants elle est resté
attentif par exemple une expérience
aussi longtemps réalité virtuelle ça
n'avait jamais été fait quand elle est
sortie en 2017 et dans l'équipe nous
avons été très étonnés par la
concentration que les visiteurs gardait
tout au long de ces cinquante minutes
pendant 50 minutes les visiteurs
écoutent six combattants leur parler ils
sont attentifs parce que ce que disent
les combattants est très fort mais c'est
pas la seule raison
grâce à l'immersion apportée par la
réalité virtuelle
on a l'impression d'avoir de vraies
personnes devant nous on se comporte
donc comme quand on est devant une vraie
personne dans la réalité on se place à
une distance raisonnable on le regarde
dans les yeux et on écoute avec
attention
je sais pas vous mais moi j'ai du mal à
rester absorbée par une interview de 50
minutes à la télévision on peut le faire
en réalité virtuelle
ce qu'on a découvert aussi c'est que le
simple fait de devoir se déplacer pour
écouter ce que les combattants à nous
dire est suffisant à nous impliquer de
l'immersion et de l'interactivité
découle donc l'implication un concept
très fort et plutôt rares en dehors de
la vie réelle quand on est impliqué on
décuple notre attention
notre compréhension votre mémorisation
et on est aussi plus ouvert
émotionnellement et donc on est plus
apte à se mettre à la place de notre
interlocuteur ça c'est l'empathie et
l'empathie est traduit par des
changements de comportement on peut voir
par exemple les participants se
rapprocher de plus en plus des
combattants au fur et à mesure qu'il
leur parle une connexion émotionnelle
s'est créé et les visiteurs sont en
général assez secoué à la fin de
l'expérience ils ont passé du temps avec
des personnes a priori dangereuses mais
au final qui ont un point de vue très
humain qui souligne l'absurdité de ces
guerres et qu'ils les questionne même
sur leurs propres conditions
en fait ils ont les bénéfices d'une
rencontre improbable et potentiellement
risquée en toute sécurité
ce genre de traitement de l'actualité
avec la réalité virtuelle peut donc
avoir un impact sur notre sur nos
actions futures et même la relation
qu'ont et aux autres cette force pour
l'implication l'empathie la prise de
conscience est là actuellement mesurer
scientifiquement notamment par
l'université de stanford
la bad et des chercheurs y teste par
exemple si la réalité virtuelle peut
modifier notre comportement face à des
événements qui peuvent se produire cette
foi dans l'avenir comme les conséquences
du réchauffement climatique
dans une de leurs études il place
virtuellement des personnes dans un
fonds sous marins
elles ont accès à des informations et à
peu voir la faune et la flore autour
d'eux se transformer et disparaître
il en ressort un gain en compréhension
et en intérêt à propos du réchauffement
climatique les plus importants une
propension à devenir pro environnement
et donc à agir concrètement pour sa
survie en d'autres termes si j'assiste
aux conséquences du réchauffement même
virtuellement je vais faire beaucoup
beaucoup plus attention
ses causes c'est donc un moyen très
efficace de changer les comportements et
il y à beaucoup d'autres intérêts à
voyager dans le futur avec la réalité
virtuelle
elle est de plus en plus utilisés dans
la formation dans l'éducation
on va prendre de meilleures décisions on
va agir plus précisément plus
efficacement si on a déjà simulé
si on a déjà expérimenté le futur et
vous vous souvenez tout à l'heure quand
je vous ai dit qu'ils avaient voyagé
dans le futur pour préparer cette
conférence
donc je vous avais pas trop menti mais
bon vous êtes plus beau dans le réel par
contre vous remarquez que je vous parle
pas des technologies elles mêmes des
dispositifs qui servent à faire
l'expérience de la réalité virtuelle
c'est parce que peu importe la technique
le concept restera toujours le même nous
immerger et nous permettre d'interagir
dans des mondes artificielle avec des
équipements qui évolue sans cesse qui
vont de plus en plus intégrés à nos vies
et même s'intégrer à nos corps pour le
meilleur comme on l'a vu jusqu'ici
peut-être aussi pour le pire mais
aujourd'hui je vais pas vous parler des
billets possible de la réalité virtuelle
ça demanderait une autre conférence
et en parlant de futures est-ce que vous
avez déjà entendu parler de mondes
persistants les mondes persistants
ce sont des environnements virtuels
auquel on peut se connecter de n'importe
où n'importe quand et qui ne s'arrête
jamais ils sont utilisés dans certains
jeux vidéo déjà depuis plusieurs années
et ils peuvent rassembler des milliers
de personnes ce sont d'autres espaces
temps parallèle à notre réalité
mais avec leurs propres règles ce qui
est intéressant ici c'est que ces monde
ont leur propre passé présent et futur
ils ont leur propre histoire la réalité
virtuelle permet déjà d'accéder avec nos
sens à certains de ces mondes
c'est donc pas juste machine à voyager
dans le temps c'est une machine à
voyager dans les espaces temps il se
peut même que cette réalité où nous
sommes maintenant soit on fait une
dimension à laquelle on accède sans
savoir à partir d'un autre
espace temps avec un système de réalité
virtuelle ultra performant je vous
laisse réfléchir à ça l'humanité a
toujours créé des mondes artificielle
imaginaire ou réaliste par la parole les
écrits la peinture le théâtre la réalité
virtuelle
c'est un moyen incroyable de
s'affranchir des contraintes d'espacé de
temps pour vivre ce monde et y évoluer
librement
c'est plus qu'un accès à l'information
c'est même plus qu'être témoins c'est
être soi même acteur et sans risque et
ça ça permet de mieux comprendre notre
réalité de mieux nous connaître nous
mêmes et de prendre de meilleures
décisions
merci de m'avoir accompagné dans ce
voyage dans le temps
[Applaudissements]